Tradutor: Vitória Smania
Revisor: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Bom, boa tarde.
Jornalista não sabe falar
sem papel na mão,
então vocês me desculpem pelas anotações.
Bom, meu nome é Adriana Carranca,
eu sou jornalista e escritora,
eu conto histórias.
E é sobre isso, sobre o poder
de contar histórias,
que eu gostaria de falar hoje com vocês.
As histórias, elas ficam pra eternidade,
quando não há mais memória.
Elas escrevem, na verdade,
a nossa existência.
Histórias que não são contadas,
é como se nunca existissem.
Elas são esquecidas com o tempo,
quando não houver mais memória.
A primeira experiência,
o primeiro contato que eu tive
com a importância de contar histórias
foi no Sudão do Sul,
num campo de refugiados
na fronteira de Uganda.
Era noite, estava tudo muito escuro,
uma completa escuridão,
e eu ouvi à distância...
Eu tinha ido ao campo
pra saber como eles viviam,
naquela situação, à noite,
e eu ouvi à distância uma música
e me aproximei,
não sosseguei enquanto
não chegasse perto daquela música
e soubesse o que estava acontecendo.
E então eu descobri
que eles contavam histórias.
Eram refugiados, tinham fugido
da guerra, deixado tudo para trás,
suas casas, roupas, objetos, fotografias.
E a única coisa que restava
a eles era a memória.
E eles estavam, então, tentando
compartilhar essa memória,
os adultos com as crianças,
pra poder continuar existindo.
Sem isso, é como se eles
não fizessem parte da nossa história.
Nós só sabemos do passado
através das histórias que nós contamos
e registramos de alguma forma.
A vida de cada um de nós aqui
é uma história de não ficção.
E ela é um trecho da narrativa
da nossa existência.
A questão, então, que se coloca é:
"Quais histórias contar?"
"Com que histórias nós estamos construindo
a narrativa da nossa existência?"
Eu vou contar um pouquinho
da minha história
em busca de história dos outros
ao redor do mundo.
Essa história começou quando eu ganhei
uma bolsa de estudos pra ir pra Londres,
e, na minha classe, nós éramos
60 alunos de 45 países.
A minha melhor amiga era uma egípcia
e nas férias de primavera
ela nos convidou pra ir passar
as férias com ela no Egito,
porque a família dela havia
destacado três pretendentes
entre os quais ela deveria
escolher um pra se casar.
Então, nós fomos, as três amigas:
eu, nascida católica não praticante,
que decidi não ter religião
pra poder escrever sobre
as religiões com maior isenção;
a Geraldine, que é
uma filipina protestante;
a Jilian, que era uma judia canadense;
pra ajudar a Dina, muçulmana,
egípcia, a escolher um marido.
E quando os jovens estão
cortejando as meninas no Egito,
eles paparicam as amigas,
então foi a melhor viagem
que a gente já fez.
(Risos)
A gente ganhou presentes,
foi andar de barco no rio Nilo,
a gente recebia flores todos os dias.
Mas o que mais me marcou daquela viagem
foi que quando a gente voltava pro quarto,
nós quatro reunidas ali,
nós éramos só quatro meninas
conversando sobre o que meninas
e meninos conversam no mundo inteiro:
sobre amor, amizade, família, futuro,
trabalho, escola, universidade, etc.
Ali não havia judia, católica,
protestante, muçulmana,
não havia egípcia, brasileira,
não existia absolutamente
nada que nos diferenciasse.
E eu comecei a me perguntar
se isso era verdade,
se a narrativa que a gente
ouve de certos lugares,
ela não é a narrativa completa
da realidade que acontece
no solo, no campo.
Então, eu voltei pro Egito
depois, pro casamento da Dina.
Ela não se casou com nenhum daqueles três,
casou com um outro que ela conheceu
num sambão em Londres.
(Risos)
E quando eu fui pro casamento da Dina...
Esta é ela e a Geraldine.
A primeira imagem que eu tive
da hostilidade e do ódio
entre árabes e judeus
foi esta imagem,
dessa amizade entre as duas.
Então, pra mim nunca houve essa inimizade,
porque a minha primeira percepção
desse conflito foi através da amizade.
Quando fui ao Egito pro casamento
da Dina, eu decidi ir de lá pro Irã.
E eu tinha a imagem de que eu ia encontrar
um país destruído
pela guerra, empobrecido,
um país economicamente
destruído por sanções econômicas,
isolado, mulheres oprimidas.
E eu fiz uma escala nos Emirados Árabes
pra comprar um véu, porque é
obrigatório no Irã o uso do véu.
Quando você entra
no espaço aéreo iraniano,
o comissário de bordo
te avisa pra colocar o "hijab",
avisa as mulheres, porque é lei no país.
Então, eu fui ao shopping nessa escala
pra pedir ajuda às meninas
pra eu comprar um véu
e chamei-as pra um café,
porque queria saber como é que era viver,
como é que era ser essas mulheres
cuja imagem eu tinha
de serem mulheres oprimidas.
Mas, nesse café, antes
da gente começar a conversar,
uma das meninas, esta que está de óculos,
que é uma designer
dessas roupas pretas,
do "niqab",
ela falou: "Eu queria fazer uma pergunta.
É verdade que as brasileiras
fazem muitas plásticas?"
Eu falei: "É verdade. Por quê?"
Ela falou: "Nossa, que opressão!
Isso é que é opressão feminina,
você ser obrigada
a se submeter a cirurgias
pra poder circular
e ser aceita na sociedade".
Então pra mim, o que eu via
como opressão, pra ela era libertador.
A forma que ela se vestia
era uma forma de liberdade,
porque sob o "niqab",
ela podia ser quem ela quisesse.
E aí eu percebi que a narrativa
que a gente contava
dessas regiões e dessas mulheres
ignorava uma parte
importante da narrativa,
que era a visão delas próprias,
de como elas veem o mundo.
Bom, de lá eu fui então pro Irã.
E eu cheguei no Irã vestida com o "niqab",
com toda aquela bagagem
que eu tinha sobre o Irã,
do que eu achava que ia encontrar no Irã.
E eu fui recebida no aeroporto,
eu tinha marcado com a minha tradutora,
e à distância eu avistei uma menina
de calça jeans, All Star cor-de-rosa,
uma batinha colorida
e o véu que mal cobria o cabelo.
E quando eu me aproximei,
ela olhou para mim e falou:
"Mas o que você está fazendo
vestida deste jeito?
(Risos)
Nós, iranianas, somos muito modernas".
E nós fomos pro centro de Teerã
no carro dela, ela dirigindo,
ouvindo "funk" iraniano.
(Risos)
E aí eu percebi que também no Irã,
a narrativa que eu ouvia do Irã
não era completa.
No Irã, eu conheci mulheres incríveis,
que se vestem das mais diferentes formas.
Advogadas, cineastas, estudantes.
Eu descobri que elas ocupam
70% das vagas nas universidades,
50% da força de trabalho.
A primeira mulher a ganhar
um Nobel da Paz é uma iraniana.
O primeiro Nobel da Paz pro Irã
vem das mãos de uma mulher, Shirin Ebadi.
Só que essas histórias não cabiam,
elas não se encaixavam
na narrativa da época sobre o Irã.
Na época se falava muito
do programa nuclear iraniano,
então só as histórias de violência
se encaixavam realmente nessa narrativa
e as outras histórias eram ignoradas.
Eu fui então tentar descobrir
outras histórias, ver outros lugares,
e descobrir se realmente a narrativa
desses lugares não estava completa.
Então, de lá eu fui pro Afeganistão.
As narrativas têm sido muito usadas
pra nos fazer apoiar ofensivas militares.
Então, quem não se lembra do Iraque,
das armas de destruição
em massa no Iraque.
Nós acreditamos naquilo e apoiamos.
A maioria dos americanos na época
apoiou a guerra no Iraque,
porque foi exposta a uma narrativa
de que no Iraque havia armas
de destruição em massa.
O mesmo com relação às afegãs,
as mulheres sob as burcas
que a gente deveria salvar
por uma ação militar.
E eu fui pro Afeganistão
e descobri, sob essas burcas,
histórias também tão incríveis
quanto as que eu tinha descoberto no Irã.
Você tem uma série de questões
pelas quais elas estão lutando,
elas lutam por seus direitos.
O governo tenta oprimi-las,
tenta limitar o seu papel na sociedade,
mas houve uma frase muito importante
que eu ouvi da Shirin Ebadi,
que é a Nobel da Paz iraniana.
Quando eu fui entrevistá-la,
ela me recebeu com um véu
e como eu sabia que ela defendia
a liberdade feminina, eu perguntei a ela:
"Shirin, por que você está usando véu,
mesmo dentro de casa,
com a sua história
de defesa da liberdade?"
Ela falou: "Porque eu
não defendo não usar o véu,
eu defendo a liberdade da escolha,
mesmo que seja
pra escolher usar o "hijab".
E se eu tivesse essa liberdade,
eu escolheria usá-lo".
E aí, eu percebi
que aquilo pelo que ela luta
é aquilo pelo que todos nós lutamos,
não há diferença entre nós,
mulheres e homens,
todos nós lutamos pelo direito
de ter liberdade de escolha.
Então, as afegãs também lutam por isso.
E você tem mulheres como esta professora,
que educou 150 meninas dentro da sua casa,
secretamente, durante o regime do Talibã;
você tem esta deputada;
a primeira mulher a concorrer
à presidência do Afeganistão;
a editora da primeira
revista feminina do Afeganistão;
a comandante do primeiro
batalhão feminino do Afeganistão,
que está tentando humanizar
mais as ações militares.
Ela tem um "blog" de poesia,
ela estava pra se casar
nas semanas seguintes
com um jovem dez anos
mais novo do que ela,
de outra etnia e de uma patente
inferior a ela no exército,
que tinha se apaixonado por ela
ao ler as poesias que ela escrevia,
sem saber que ela era
uma comandante do exército.
E eles iam se casar,
quebrando todos os tabus
possíveis existentes no Afeganistão.
A Shamsia é a primeira
grafiteira de Cabul,
que está redesenhando os muros
destruídos pela guerra com a sua arte.
A primeira boxeadora afegã
a participar de um campeonato mundial,
ela luta no mesmo estádio
em que as mulheres antes
eram julgadas e condenadas,
muitas vezes ao apedrejamento.
E ela escolheu lutar nesse ginásio
como uma forma de resistência pacífica,
de mostrar que a luta
dessa nova geração é outra.
Eu encontrei as mesmas histórias,
eu poderia ficar aqui dias falando,
no Paquistão, Indonésia, Turquia,
Israel, Gaza, Cisjordânia,
no Congo, Sudão, África do Sul,
Etiópia, México, Haiti.
Em todos esses lugares
essas histórias existem,
só que o que acontece
é que muitas vezes elas são invisíveis.
E o problema de não dar espaço
na narrativa pra histórias pacíficas
e pra esses atores não violentos,
se só os atores que usam
da violência dominam a narrativa,
a mensagem que a gente manda
para aqueles que tentam mudar as coisas
através de ações não violentas
é de que o único caminho possível
é ter uma arma na mão.
É essa mensagem que a gente diz pra eles.
Se essas histórias pacíficas
não têm voz, não têm espaço,
não causam nenhuma pressão
e, portanto, nenhuma reação.
Eles se cansam de tentar
mudar as coisas através
de ações não violentas.
E muitos deles passam pra ações violentas.
Nós vivemos hoje uma luta de narrativas,
essa é a grande guerra
que nós vivemos no mundo hoje.
As histórias que nós contamos têm
um impacto direto e concreto na realidade.
Isso tem sido estudado
por vários cientistas,
O MIT tem um departamento exclusivo
pra estudar a correlação
entre como o nosso cérebro funciona
quando exposto a diferentes narrativas
e como isso pode impulsionar a violência.
Emile Bruneau é um professor do MIT
que cuida desse departamento...
Os pesquisadores já tinham
descoberto, por exemplo,
que quando você lê sobre
o sofrimento de outras pessoas,
uma área do seu cérebro é ativada
e é a mesma área de quando
você está sofrendo aquela dor, você mesmo.
A conclusão a que se chega é que nós todos
somos capazes de desenvolver empatia,
nós sentimos a dor do outro.
Mas os pesquisadores descobriram
também que isso só é verdade
quando o objeto da violência
nos é familiar, ou seja,
só quando nós nos relacionamos
com aquela vítima da violência
é que ela causa essa reação
de empatia na gente.
Isso explica, por exemplo,
porque, quando existem atentados
em Nova Iorque ou em Paris,
a nossa reação, a reação mundial
e na internet também
é muito maior do que, por exemplo,
um atentado na Nigéria.
Porque nós nos colocamos mais no lugar
das pessoas que estão na França
ou nos Estados Unidos,
porque, talvez, nós visitamos
mais esses lugares
e nós pouco ouvimos falar sobre a Nigéria,
a Nigéria não tem espaço
na narrativa que está sendo escrita hoje,
e, portanto, a Nigéria
nos é um lugar muito pouco familiar.
E cientificamente,
nosso cérebro não reage à violência
sofrida por pessoas na Nigéria.
Os pesquisadores também descobriram
que mesmo quando a gente é capaz
de desenvolver a empatia,
existe uma reação contrária que é:
você desenvolve empatia por um grupo
e isso faz com que você apoie a violência,
inconscientemente, de outro grupo.
Em todos os filmes, a gente está sempre
torcendo pro mocinho contra os bandidos,
mesmo que o mocinho pratique
atos de violência também.
Então, isso acaba perpetuando a violência.
É o que os pesquisadores chamam
de "gap" da empatia, falha da empatia.
É uma falha no sistema de empatia.
A resposta do nosso cérebro só é diferente
quando nós somos expostos
a histórias positivas,
histórias em que existe o sofrimento,
mas o foco da história
é uma ação positiva,
que está conseguindo
transformar aquela situação.
Nesse caso e só nesse caso,
a reação do nosso cérebro
é de conforto e de altruísmo.
Isso tem um impacto na gente,
no desejo de ajudar e de contribuir
com aquela mudança
que está sendo mostrada.
E aqui reside, precisamente,
o poder de contar histórias,
o poder que hoje
está nas mãos de todos nós.
Porque, hoje, todos vocês podem
contar histórias na sua "timeline"
ao compartilhar
ou a disseminar informação.
Os pesquisadores, no entanto,
também descobriram
que na internet nós também
temos uma tendência maior
a compartilhar só aquilo
que nos é familiar.
Nós temos só os nossos amigos,
nas nossas redes sociais,
e nós só compartilhamos o pensamento
de pessoas que são parecidas com a gente.
E isso, no lugar de desenvolver a empatia,
aumenta as distâncias,
reforça as diferenças
e está provocando
um declínio da nossa capacidade
de desenvolver empatia pelo outro.
Isso foi uma pesquisa
também feita até 2009,
que avaliou esse impacto da internet.
Então, se eu puder deixar
uma mensagem, hoje, pra vocês,
eu diria que:
lembrem-se que nós estamos escrevendo,
juntos, a narrativa da nossa existência.
Ao invés de promover o ódio e a violência,
compartilhem ações pacíficas
e exemplos positivos
que inspiram e transformam.
Ao invés de destacar
aquilo que nos distancia,
vamos mostrar aquilo que nos aproxima
e que nos torna iguais como humanos.
E assim é que nós vamos construir, juntos,
uma narrativa pacífica
de um mundo melhor para todos.
Obrigada.
(Aplausos)